[Music]
today's question comes from dave in
oklahoma i'm 72 and have a net worth of
over 2 million dollars way to go
my wife and i gave our children who
decided to attend college a family
scholarship they were responsible
responsible for paying whatever the
scholarship didn't cover
to qualify for the scholarship
they had to get good grades and attend
church regularly they all graduated
college using this system my first
grandchild will start college next year
so i offer the same deal to her i got an
email from her father saying she was
furious that i was trying to force her
to attend church which she already does
voluntarily and that she might quit
attending church over it
other family members think i should have
given her the money with no strings
attached
was it inappropriate for me to have some
provisions around the scholarship that
require grades and religious attendance
i think your granddaughter is a freaking
brat
she's furious because you offered her
free money and she didn't like the terms
call the ambulance
dave this is your money
you could have asked her to stand on her
head for 30 minutes in order to get it
and she has no right to be furious
she can just say i decline your kind
offer because i don't like the terms but
you don't have to be a furious little
brat
so uh
offer withdrawn
and family members that don't like it
can kiss my butt
if they get some money they get to do
with their money what they want to do
with their money
but it's your job to manage this money
you didn't do anything wrong
you have a solid value system you're a
good man you're kind you didn't do
anything wrong you didn't make a big
deal out of it
she wasn't worshiping satan and you
tried to get her to quit
she was already attending church well
smack me silly oh my gosh
sounds like she needs to spend some more
time over there than me
oh my goodness
now dude you know you you're
you're just being nicer than i would
have been
i would have just said okay get out i'm
going to take you off that list and a
couple of others until you grow up and
decide to be respectful you little twit
so there you go
see i'm kind of old school that way
i just you know
your money you decide
i don't have a right to be offended if
you don't want to put your money on
something i want you to
isn't that weird that's just people are
just so entitled see entitlement is a
form of arrogance
and that's what you're dealing with here
um bless your little heart
which southern for
yeah whatever